bon
[Musique]
on ma première saison
non
[Musique]
je n'ai pas eu de sa maman
malheureusement
c'est pas
un restaurant un soir de très bons
moments et je crois que ça a été une
saint valentin
que j'ai énormément apprécié
et ça continue puisque on fait notre
saint valentin un petit peu tous les
jours
[Musique]
non
je suis je ne veux pas répondre à cette
question c'est les gens mais je suis une
amoureuse passionnée un peu jaloux on va
dire pour un petit peu beaucoup c'est
une passionnée passionné aimant son
emprise de l'amour vraiment fougue et
[Musique]
attentionné donc drôle les expériences
de la vie m'ont appris à faire attention
à celui qu'on aime j'aime beaucoup à
voir en tout cas l'un des bisous quel
genre d'amoureux je suis je suis
amoureuse indépendant très attentionné
très sensible mais pour l'instant
racines hameau est célibataire
[Musique]
testing j'aurais dit ben ali
ben ali samsam d'heure les maldives
venise venez va mettre les combats voilà
sa magnifique la martinique où un pays
froid le canada quelque chose pour se
réchauffer sauf qu'une destination rêvée
pour moi les îles galapagos pour ma part
je dirais tight je dirais simplement les
manifs à dubaï je ne dirais pas non
toutes les destinations sont bénins du
moment qu'on crie l'affairé
[Musique]
alors pour moi la plus belle chanson
d'amour jeudi ancré à ton port de fanny
j
choix
[Musique]
non
chocolat et les deux
pour moi les deux vont très bien aux
chandelles
peut-être à tignes en tête à tête
comme pour nous cadeau pour lui
ça dépend du moment de la soirée mais on
va commencer par l'assainissement tenue
de soirée depuis ferrasse
nisa tient mais parfois tu regardes
mise et pourquoi pas
[Musique]
quelle que soit la question l'amour sera
toujours la réponse
[Musique]